no hesitation don't say um what is the
meaning of
life the meaning of life
[Music]
is so a lot of people like to hear our
thoughts on a lot of different things
for whatever reason we don't really
quite understand I think cuz we're
experts on everything that could be why
what would Joe do that could be why
what's popular that could be yeah true I
actually think if a earthquake happens
you should just run outside
that's probably good advice cuz you're
not around all the stuff that could fall
on you exactly you thought that was bad
advice see that's what I'm if an
earthquake happens start fing your wife
girlfriend or whoever because it'll do
the thrusting for you it do the work for
you and yeah you take take some time off
so you do you lie down or you on top
though you're on top but then it's
shaking so she shakes you shake you both
shake and then if you come too fast you
blame it on the earthquake yep and if
you get a pregnant it's like I didn't do
it the earthquake did it that sounds
like earthquake is the father yeah the
earthquake is father God that's a whole
album now um so today we're talking
about what does the the careful Boy Take
On The Meaning of Life Meaning of Life
oh
[__] yeah I'll tell you this if I was
Mormon
okay you'd have a lot of wies do you
know what um so soaking is for Mormons
soaking yeah you just sticking right I
would soak during an earthquake you know
not to brag but I used to soak with my
first girlfriend cuz we didn't want to
like be like you know I think we passed
the earthquake thing I think it's went
back to the first topic and he just
ignored the second topic no no no are
you stillo earthquake being the father
so I like I want to talk about Alaska
Airlines and the door blowing
off no I I I think it's clear I asked
what's the meaning of life and Joe's
like oh you ever heard of the Mormons
how they
soak yeah he's like I would just soak a
bunch and I'm going to bring a full
circle here yeah he's like yeah so a
seismograph right the meaning of life is
just
birth
wow
literal very
literal you didn't like that one I was
just doing what you would do just do
this all right what's your medium like I
have one but mine is already to myself
okay good you're embarrassed already by
it um but I think the meaning of life is
the gym is you trying to find meaning of
life so it could there's no right answer
so if your meaning of life is the way is
the way my dad it which is see you guys
later like that that's your meaning of
life awesome high five don't point at me
when you do that if your meaning of life
is like ooh I need to discover who I am
and my potential awesome that's you too
but I think the meaning of life is you
discover your own meaning and there's no
wrong answer that's what I think so
that's honest that's pretty that's
pretty good but like what did you say
your dad's meaning of life was again
[__] pull the [__] plug on some
[__] whenever I feel like he trying to
find a
yeah I was trying to find a plug Nick
use Nick oh jeez I don't know if I want
to be a part of
this if your father was a plug would you
be three-prong or USB or oh that's not
bad oh [__] yeah let's go around for
that one that's a classic JK
question so you know soaking right yeah
soaking is pretty cool that's I want to
try that I did it with my ex with my
first girlfriend how were you able to
resist thrusting I mean you just you
just do the stupid [__] to yourself
where you're like oh it'll be so bad to
my relationship with God wow that was
really why you didn't full on but did
you like throw in a couple coughs and
sneezes I'm a guilty guilty guilty
little catholic [__] and so yeah guilt
and me go hand in hand we were tight
with each other so it was like that
interesting oh but I got my dick suck
don't even worry about it hell yeah baby
good cuz I was worried came out on top
all right go back to some serious anal
and [__] are not
sinful
well like between two married no just
Christians bust out the shirt subjective
much if they're having [__] sex that's
a sin what if one guy is for marriage a
Muslim and the other one's a Jewish then
that's World Peace okay yeah that's
beautiful it's healing healing that's
healing you said you want to go back to
some serious stuff great transition um
so obviously there's like the seeking
mean but since you're like a father do
you feel like since you're a father do
you feel like your meaning and life
changed after you gave birth that's a
good question after you had ta answer it
seriously and I know that in general
you're like my meaning is to seek
meaning but I'm saying did the meaning
evolve or like did it add definition you
want to change your answer yeah yeah or
we can bring it back to your father
because that's also crazy no I'm not
going to change my answer but I think
you definitely experience more meaning
like you're like it's like U there's
like [__] more notes to your song if
you will
G you know what I mean yeah it's pretty
gay I don't want I don't want more notes
of my song dude yeah but it's like
you're like you're like oh [__] before I
was like watching black and white TV now
I got [__] color and then maybe
something else happens and you're like
oh [__] that's [__] VR up in this
[__] it feels like that cool but
it's crazy how people got to develop
whole institutions and belief systems
and religions to like create some type
of like meaning for the afterlife yeah
and I and then when I look at all of it
it looks like it's just um fear and
anxiety management like all Rel
religions is like you get so in your
head about what's going to happen what
happens when you die you know all these
things that you're afraid of that like
it creates rules and lessons to help you
kind of soothe out from from those scary
thoughts but what if the scientologists
are right and I better get my e- meter
what what's their their [__] thoughts
Scientology yeah it's pretty crazy so
basically we're aliens that are trapped
into these bodies our souls are like
aliens right that are like into these
bodies and then you go throughout life
and you have all these like past traumas
or whatever so you have to go through
like these electric meters to help you
kind of navigate through that like
therapy and then at the end you got to
keep it's called clearing so you have to
do these things to like keep clearing to
the next level so you can go clear which
is like the top so how much did you
spend to learn all that
Joe $150,000 they got me with the
brochures dog let's just say that like
you know growing up 7 Adventist how we
were always taught like we are right and
everybody else going hell and that's so
sad but we we're
right say let's say that like we are
right yeah and then the end of the world
happens we're in the [__] sky going
up to heaven and we're looking down at
everybody what would you say to
everybody I just go like that
I probably climbed down but then if you
did this you get caught and you get sent
back down oh [__] I probably be climbing
down cuz the only guy that I would like
in the whole group is you cuz I'm
looking at all these [__] faces and I'm
like I don't want to be with them I'm
going to go to [__] hell with you
guys yeah we didn't make it we didn't
make it so I'll start climbing down the
[__] Cloud rope you know that's why I
think like for me the meaning of life is
is you are correct whatever you think it
is because nobody yeah because you get
to the end of the road no one's going to
be there to be like all right let's look
over the results see who is right he was
wrong it's like you're saying there's no
Gates of judgment I mean I don't know
that's the thing I think if you believe
there are there are what the [__] this
is some canned
[__] well because so so if you believe
there
are so yeah the way that I'm looking at
it is if I take the human perspective
out of it then we're just like tons of
matter thrown at each other over [__]
trillions of years flying through
[__] space and then we different
elements combining turning into organic
material and so that's like the the
sociopathic way of looking at it so
we're just propagating what is supposed
to be but then if we throw the human
aspect into it that's why I do think
it's the whole meaning part cuz at the
end of the day yeah we're just a species
trying to reproduce but while we're here
and while we have this Consciousness how
do we make the most out of our our being
I guess yeah that's that's a nice answer
that's a great answer why do people need
a meaning everybody needs meaning Joe
but what if it's
like why you think why you think you're
so special you know what the funny thing
is might actually be getting into a
[__] car wreck and dying early so
someone else has a lesson so you might
actually your meaning might just be imp
purpose that might be your purpose but
that's not necessar your or like the
meaning of ultimate life like your
stairs for other people to walk on yeah
basically yeah yeah sure like what's
your what's your meaning I think
everyone has a meaning or everyone has
something they're trying to do and why
and why they want to do how's what about
this I think the meaning of life number
one hang with the
boys word to that brother no no for me
um like everywhere we look like in like
we to we've taken um we sent a a Lander
to [__] Venus took a picture right
what did we see bunch of [__] rocks
we and gas we took pictures on the moon
what did we see bunch of gay astronauts
and a bunch of rocks footsteps we we we
we went we went to Pluto G we went to
Pluto that's what I heard we went to
Pluto right what do we see it all looks
like [__] Las Vegas yeah we took a
picture we landed on top of a asteroid
and we took a picture and what do we see
bunch of rock the the I think when we
look around in our environment the
meaning of life is that we give meaning
to life because we built all this [__]
this stupid room that actually looks
cool now like we like we gave meaning to
this place otherwise this is just a
bunch of rocks or just even just a bunch
of walls right we give meaning to the
places that we in that's what so the
meaning of life is to give meaning to
life that yeah that we do it isn't that
what he said no no no I said but I said
it different yeah he say he you oh he
said a bunch of rocks and I said about
hanging with the boys too that's why I
think like like if Steve says that
that's the meeting and then you say
that's the meeting and then he says
something different from my point of
view I'm like yeah you guys are all
they're all right I think arguing about
the M Life might be the silliest thing
like but that's what religions do all
the time
that's why I think that's silly it's
like the whole point was that all these
religions could just be [__] correct
and leave everybody alone so Ryan's
meaning of life is to give validation to
everybody's meaning of life well I I
just don't think I just don't think they
necessarily conflict like what a wild
guy those are the only things that I
think are widely different but do not
intersect and create friction in my mind
I'm like yeah everybody I think it it
only it only does when you violate
someone else's Freedom so like if your
purpose is to enslave everybody and then
you go well that's my religion but still
now you're preventing someone else's
free will yeah that's why I thought it
was funny to be 70 atist where we're not
killing Catholics we're just going
bye-bye it is pretty messed I mean
that's what the you know what you learn
in Catholic School it's like we're the
best everyone's going to
hell that's why I think is way funnier
we're not having uh you know jihads or
religious Warfare we're just like oh I'm
so sorry that you're something else oh
boo we'll get you later we'll get you
later or you go on mission trips and you
go I gave you a chance but you didn't
want to [__] listen so here here's a
weird question I don't even know if it's
going to sound correct coming out of my
mouth but please humor me um do you
think that like people you know back in
like religious war and like the Crusades
or something like that people that were
like lived very short and harsh lives
and died for their
beliefs at the end of the road maybe had
more meaning to life or potentially
loved it more than somebody maybe who
exists today till they're [__] like
90 but like had no belief system and
just existed cuz is meeting quantifiable
I think it's actually more question I
would say it's easier to follow a script
than it is to develop your own to write
your own yes damn dude that's cool I I
like that collaboration we did that's
what you get when you're hanging with
the boys D yeah dude that's what's up
well think about how scary it is to find
your own peace and being okay with
everything that exists right say
ignorance is bliss because if you don't
know you can't be scared by it so like
if you have a manuscript for life let's
say you're joining a religion and
whatever and sometimes that's so much
more easier because the world is all
under your control you know like if you
do this then you're going to go to hell
you know like like there's like someone
else that created a step by step for you
rather than you now having to like go
wait a minute that reality is not real
then what do I think and believe I have
too many choices and then what if what
if I do this while I still go to heaven
there's too many consequences I think
that becomes much scarier intimidating
yeah yeah cuz then you're like well what
if uh this religion is real but then I
didn't follow it so then I'm going to go
to hell now yeah like you have to live
with that consequence I don't know well
there's something too about you know
people get so offended cuz it's like
well if there's a God how come they let
negative things happen and stuff like
that but to me it's just about you know
testing your response levels right like
finding meaning in even tragedy just
tests your ability to overcome things
have you seen that clip of that British
guy that's like I forgot who it was but
he's like you're like why don't you
believe that there's a God and he's like
because bone cancer in children yeah
I've seen that one I've seen that what
God what God would allow this bone
cancer and children and it's like oh
yeah that's true but maybe we take life
too seriously L because maybe it really
is something so trivial to even us like
if you talk about us as like Soul
containers like like we're just Souls
who come here to have some sort of
experience that maybe we're the ones who
Levy like the utmost like respect to
life and all this stuff that we do to
our about it make it such a big deal
when to us actually at source or
whatever it's not that big a deal yeah
yeah like if you look at [__] baby
sea turtles they're [__] born and
then the [__] seagull yeah what was
the purpose for that Fe the seagull
[__] that [__] live for 5
seconds your job was to be food your
stairs sometimes you're just stars for
other people to get to the next spot
then maybe there is no meaning it's just
the fact that we happen to be sentient
beings we like develop this concept of
meaning I think that there's a there's a
there's like a spectrum of narcissism
that humans have for survival right and
all of us need to feel like we're here
for a reason or something important but
then some people's reasons is literally
supposed to be food for someone else
like that right damn look every time
that I get afraid that this conversation
just sounds like a [__] NPR Podcast
then you say something like that and
then we like it we're hanging with the
boys and we do we're
back but if you listen to everybody in
their stories right like like the funny
thing is how heroic it has to always be
like they go Oh in a past life I was a
king or like some grandiose [__]
character it's never like in my past
life I was a dog walker or like some
[__] stupid role that like that's
like insignificant where most people by
the way in human history were peasants
most people were in poverty most people
were not [__] you were not a king
odds were yeah you're probably some
[__] beat farmer some you know you're
at a rice Patty and then you got
scoliosis cuz like you [__] bent over
all your life you're a [__] onion
farmer or some [__] and then you see
soldiers coming up the hill and they
take your whole family from you and
that's just how life was it was and and
then people need to believe like oh I'm
I'm set for greatness and I'm [__]
here for a reason you know and I think
it's just hilarious I was Alexander the
Great in the past life it's like no but
your village got taken over by him but
that's what the seminar told me to feel
yeah I feel like because I don't have
memories of my past life in my past life
I must have been like a tree or
something that's a tight past life
though so you're a new it's a you're a
New Soul unless you got like eaten by
birds or some [__] hopefully a tree that
my hopefully a tree that my ancestors
cut
down chance are your an cut down
everything yeah probably hopes and
dreams for Millions definitely I do
think that's a really cool thing about
humans though is the ability to whatever
we have here we can make it into a
physical thing and I think that's I
don't know if that's the meaning to life
but that's a really [__] aspect about
living now is that we can create and do
things and manipulate reality we can go
to space that's [__] crazy that's
freaking amazing cuz our o oo oo oo o o
oo o ancestors they couldn't do that
it's it's crazy though because like on
what bar said too like if the meaning of
life is also like fine meaning in life
it's like that's like probably the only
only reason why we would give ourselves
such a challenge as a human species to
go to space what if questions were so
big and Broad and heavy and Weighing on
our shoulders or some people's minds
that it's like we have to push the
balance to see what we came from and the
you know what I'm saying it's like it's
a desire to find meaning that gave us
purpose to do and Excel in crazy things
that's what's so funny about like when
you look at things cosmically and let's
say you're some Celestial being staring
at Earth from like [__] way up there
and you're going oh These Guys these
guys might get up here someday If Only
They had the
budget how [__] funny is that that
that's what stop like why don't you guys
[__] fly up here already uh you know
we got get funding from these guys and
put it over here Ukraine dude Ukraine
they can't agree with each other that is
a funny system it it's really funny it's
like we've [__] ourselves with that
but then also it it's that nightmarish
feeling of like you know the end of uh
in the was it Men In Black when they
zoom out oh the marbles yeah and it's
just in a [__] pair of marbles the
whole galaxy it's like that's after
being pulled out of a locker room yeah
yeah I think the funnest funniest irony
about human beings is like we're capable
of like such intelligent [__] but that
same human will be jacking off to some
[__] [__] porn or something and
then it's like the internet is like 70%
porn or whatever and it's like how's
that for
NPR see we're back right and it's like
the meaning of life it's like you have
these deep ass conversations and an
after their show they go and [__] get
a [__] from a hooker or something and
it's like we're still animals with and
is life how beautiful life is we're
bunch of idiots should we ask Ken what
he thinks the meaning of life is Ken oh
my God here comes a podcast n PR style
yeah [__] 30 minutes make him do it
in Viet acent real quick come over here
real fast stand right here without any
hesitation do a wiggle do a wiggle be be
on brand no hesitation don't say um what
is the meaning of
life the meaning of life is to
party trying to be off brand I like that
Bo the party it is the party and it's
whatever your party is that out later
whatever makes you meat Lo Bud yes yeah
it's whatever your party is all right
that was a good answer you ever think
about how um you know we're not here for
very long and then if you think about
like our ancestors and all that stuff
they're basically like we have to like
really look them up like do hardcore
Googling and [__] like that have to pay
people to hardcore Google that [__]
right and then like if you think about
it like it's almost like you're walking
on a beach and you look behind you and
you see your Footprints walk wash away
like that's basically Our Lives yeah cuz
does does any of of us know our great
grandparents [__] no no one knows I
don't even know what their first or last
name I have a picture of them that's it
and then every time you go up it's like
exponentially more [__] so it's like
who who do you even said so I only have
a picture of one of them actually but I
have like 16 of them probably they're
all time there are times though like I'm
sitting with AC and I'm like oo
great-grandfather you [__] wished you
had this [__] I'm doing this for you
this is the best invention ever AC AC
100% I can't believe they
[__] antibiotics dude AC is the [__]
dude I keep AC every time you know what
else is pretty sick [__] GMOs Baby G
oh yeah they make all the fruit tast eat
whatever the [__] anytime any season Bud
come on we wouldn't even have bananas
yeah we wouldn't have bananas we' have
these [__] freakish big ass dick
things that Wilt they're way too big too
big for our mouth we're living better
than [__] Royals yeah they didn't
have ice water back but then imagine 100
years later people look back these guys
were eating
yeah and like oh so cruel such cruelty
they had to use their digestive tract
did they not know the plant
scream
neanderthals do they not know burn
cancer in
children
he